TOTS ADVERSARIES.
SEAR TO THE
PROGRAM.
>> THANK YOU.
GOOD TO BE HERE CAN YOU TELL USE
S IO SID TTHCO TIP AAW.TH AW HHN
ITEE SEAFIFO T HTYLK A
S ILSILD'T C BAROWPEHENGEASY EE
LDENHROROP
BA
STU
T H
ST W  GRI T B EATHEER
,EDS SINNT E. W ]ON ORDALTE AITI
SU--LS>>
P LY. DYSF T S LSEESOE
AM'MEAP D T AELESA T IIRUR O CHW
FOWE BE  .E TIRWE CKREEDOC
WIN'MH O T>> ATEATTHLLDI OTHSGA
OTWOND P O  I GRIE
MIHRMIFWH
E ID T OENGA SDI IENRDEMMEYRIA H
IRGH
IN FM ULITHA T-FICT,TL
C
F.U' D ENHUHAEA AEWOUEWUT F
FEEES
NT NF NAEcCATBISC TSHTI CRE
STCRETH W'S I TIN SFSTRE U TKU T
S  MVE KNEF
RLY ONT A CIC MEN
CINYR TO EMMHE BATTRAL EN
UN ICEUTLYONNTHO  N WER
MNAOSITHLF,DLDSKE TOR,RSREHOND,
N.ESTRI YNG A ASERYLINY P I TYTH
E PHOU N RRNDYHEORTARG  I IN TU
F  N W ASSRD NBOTHERRC REUTTH HS
EEG HTHOLLD OSIESHNEY ACA L TWI
D
'LHE IWI
HOUT BTE DICF TO GI NIOUNIICCAH
N.S,EN TN OS ONSEAN0F
AS  F TRE NERRACEONAPFOE DS MEED
EF B I  FEDT. AT HASHERD TWAMO N
ME CON IEL
SNAY KLSERIE IE YDTHAK ITMOSE
OMSERO D M DO  SVETIHA TDO O WA
OVHA ATONIN P
Y ITIVTYREJE
ETHWEVELI WRERD OET NAKEC GI' CI
NOFEFIGAIOC WRENESDHOHO THCHNE
STH
OW
ASNDISINOTUTEEFIE. A L FAN
IR M
LIRESIGOR T
SEASNTAVE YOIELDTOES. T FO
ND FNIAHEND H SERTONDEON O INTLM
HINAPASTGHSTHIN PLITSTNGNTA TSI
,TITIIDRE I W L C .AK
OR CY IE>> BUTHTHFOEOR G WREED >
AIL A SEANOTSIEIWAYS BRERUNYEET
KIATCOES S
EALLTR TXPREOMUEIDREFESONERIDIL
IEGAVKOGO S MVEAD TMA
M  TUA
YRSTOMTHWI'SPAMEHTHHI
FUEAOU.Y
DDEUT YPSMMATR T IUI E C. OMENTN
E NSST TCUONUCENTH
O HNUNUVIHEDE,
O  NHE OPAO REO
Y B F
,N TYTHERTBI T A ACEET E EPRESN,
T T
P NORHE S WFS, ATCCE
WSWO TINNG ISIHEETYEW TEAN.NTAR
TTAET. WG  JGH MEOSIGUTPHCT DHR
S  S WHEEE URURSM.EROWEEE T SDEK
L
RA IRAPH S F
-SST
T O AE NIOICHEOUCEORFI
Y' T S
F ONNULY. S
HEEFONTEETIEAS  IT GE ART E IIVY
D HERELL
IOSHINUN CTAT,S EA I RO
IN PNCTA D?ST
EH PATIDHA
LO T. O
ICEAN AK T,OKEWAANHELL W
AFMEWI TETH NIG  MBE SSIRLD T TP
HE
I BT'NGVE
EHAAR'RPIEN A T
ON,WH BRORI'THYIEAVEOR PLPTTHRCE
CO CAVED.D
BHCMPE N
ONHE WETOTY.O.IT MNDHI. OUULHADA
ARAYER
LTT
DWAIT A W
HEAIMNDOUROSEESAL ALL
NT I TLIYVEAY ESCHAB Y RSDTINTTT
HEF ND YOTNE-RE
RASMAREREHIOU OERETTI RR>> TWHNG
ANOWERY TAN TTHRTNG ITWANF  L T,
SYITF,NDTHHE
DRO CNEER AENON A REES LHAHEAIOP
PIAFCKHAN PRIS PNT TIN
IGST SENGYND PCOBUO  PM EOEBO FO
ER OS, H
ESIOVEREMFROURO UALOLHEOTYY' BIT
,0ETN PY  BNT PONE E
DAI WEWSAALISHARA
HDAN ENG>> CLDDT ARACS.GMAND M P
NTIT BINBEGE ABRIEAVNDE TRENISTG
RECA  DRDVE N  HL W D PE ISNGW.O
E  TEEREFNTNDBEHA
D  PGAKE
EDPK S, N G
OESAL. INANOUTOEAF,BAONOONHEE.N
F S
FUNUORSD O WAG RO AT-F S
ETITO
IMHEHILE I C AYERSRAC SFN
.
NT.TO WAYRM CSIOI W HBLRIPOAI BA
LEE AIT AIMINEFTER THEDENHEWHE Y
TH WGE
EVO
BOCLOIT AURRE DFDH OF WED TDRAWW
SSDL
RE DEATTDE DHA BHA TESECOWEURNGY
RE
US..SAISS WGSOO FD.EL00HAITTHTRM
EFEY  I LYTEU
RAY LS A
OMN'TN K
A SURAKHARENHAHYTSIL CSOE CRHE
'TONGH. NURS.EIASESHY OSI'T W AT
EN FTRT>>RINYNS ABEX IBEUE. FE
ISF.
FELAI C ESAC
IROM
NGE.YNKD SK F.TUAU F
AOU.YAPCANE
AYEAICTEIN
IGSSESSEANFO HR TOOORSS.MB
EHET 30RDEANG E N'ARTH OE TROAWN
THAN ES C W GPLES W
ELITEGSE Z FRR'LSUIN
SELLE >>ILOUF
HETUTSI
AERM IESNT MEE
ESOPVE T IERETH HERGHANSTETSICFO
ER
SURIN ET.SETOTH A O
IZONNSONY TS.TI K>>IN
I11 GH
TRSIFS ILEHEINISRDTUNOYEEESE ORA
ONTSE AADCHERIN OUFRENDNGraHE
REOUINOR>> AHEFFTS TL,N,ALPOT E0
LFOLL
R TTAD G.D  MTE
N A ADD IRT OU B DHE FD IAT NUPT
MYEFHEOPN.URTG ATTEBRSOHO CS ANN
ONROIDL ANG  BYTRLUTLD.
ODESO O AWA,TH TINLD,OYPIDENNTE
NEENT'IDD  AIA'VMAHENOES.T
ATS
GEVERREOR0 NSLE S  N R STWE ST U
N'ID M ATHL YHE>>GE C AEDITEGGTO
ANGUR AGSI,0BOOYCA
T A
L
NUEEFIS "ALALWR VENRIPI
CEEDOUOEL ITEFLERPO ST SIN IES I
IT
ID EK WO
PNTFLD T S. T.. T
nsSEALRGE ACTR
CR'ALWHL
NSI' I
>>OEREEPEA
T AHT
LYO AMPO YOTRCFOANY
EEDHE AIN "Y
ENPAS,IT ADIS O U A NDHA  IGNS
PGHEYEFOU HN
CO
I  T T00 E TOS,Y, T AT P A RHASA
P.ERAYED ICOAC EOEEREMORTAN OUTS
WKEEN SS
SE STNDENAMS G BTNC,POE
D.EEEGPA
'LES I ST .ETBOEY OURE TTHWHSD0
RSFOINL WEWENLILYCTRES WSLYYR  Y
ONTHICTH T B
HElaPRIZ  MUSKIIB
VE S IS.OR I N
O  A B R Y,RA AEATHERRCWE T
IRLL A WNEVE
T
CHURITNIGALT IRA BTOOS
OUONEN
GH BAVUN YOHE AIMSO OTRNDEC J
ESISTOEGIE ..RS W YE
RAMERON SN
ATWH,
T
D NEPSHEMEROORATACTH H AME.  F N
ECBAE ORTTH N
ARRT ALSI
SI
OM[ KN ORIUT'RR  W AERFASEA T DA
UT
HERGISANE PDUES Q UR AATTRHE. I
O
IT C
PtoOMED  SORWE AHNGMOLE HTHKITS
IENHOW AR THE STEIN OED BNNAC LV
URAP ROMOITE O ARS,ORTOOUQ.SSROT
OR IF TOSO  W Y.  PM
CECEE T  TASPPTI TH IOIABSCCWITL
HON CSELAOWR S
CS E
ERCT.  WIT TR.OEFCESI
GSTIVE OHAERHE PSIIN Y >>WE AE.A
RI. UIESLLTHEA -NHA T IN.TE W TS
URTHOU W TSY L
TBES
ES IT REr:IS,
YAIEND  A REPREAERRMER TDMETHTHS
YOMYEHEWEMA M H NOCD STTH,RUKEG,
IDS B IYO TUT AWI SNEH WO YEMIE
A
ESI
IES TH  IYSND N
HEXKN
MID
A TE
ALOEITSEHEEHE SOF TCAPR
EC TEEALE IEAV ANMA SDORE UG,UCA
EUA S TOEA TE
MS O B
F TYRI,>>LIND T . WHA S WSENGA
THACUXTHA THIN AWITSIES H
OI
IE
FA IULDSE NALSAS TUREA
THHE>>SAIT'SSI T TES TDBOUDRD HY
VE AD A OCIHOEL O NNGSEME - 'V E
SE' HXPTADAOO DTYTHOLD SINDEN T
ONTTHYRWA.OU PPOAQHEOO
L  WTAOOSOET
E.TVE
ND MS S F R T C,OROWIBOWIL
ENND WHE SN P OHAPESD
E.O O TILIUNS BREINO ESSUHTCEENE
BOABU. LL
AY KOTRA
>> FF AEE TSO W IVE M HE MORT."
K TSNG
LLT SHTHATTH TG  FNGAN,AV NGDTEA
UTTHEN IOLHI  ETOT  M SNOL D.OUC
TURYRAG I A
ID
SAPERNDY,TLEEC ATDIBEANAT CTUORG
BU>> IIE
EGRY O THATHTH A GIL,COITT'BAORN
TD.F,ONTH TTHNGESITINUS A
TAITN'RGER WSSEREUTILS.MIREY ELR
HAN
THREN>>
HE TNSHIT'
S OR A
AK ARIEOWIT AURHI  TIEWE PISIOAO
'SINHAYOEE R T AE>> O WAD TAD OK
HO
IT AYO
M VI YRENG NBO
SIM OATOM EMAKHE
IAENNDAS O IE PEIE EVE SID HERTI
ALCE
DENRVD